forcément maintenant c'est de plus en
plus difficile de trouver des gars qui
connaissent pas on enquête on a en fait
ce qui nous prend le plus de temps c'est
les enquêtes avant le piège donc on a
des faux journalistes qui vont
rencontrer nos potentiels piégés donc on
a des gens qui nous sont recommandés
[Rires]
ils montent des photos des potentiels
stagiaires et dedans il y a ma photo ah
c'est ça et c'est comme ça qu'on est
c'est comme ça qu'on te prend parce que
tu étais on va dire ils ont dit que tu
es pistonné bah on fait pas on fait
croire que c'est la production de France
Télévisions qui fait un reportage sur le
métier de la personne là c'était agent
matrimonial en plus on allait le
chercheur en Belgique il a fallu
justifier que c'était quand même pour la
télé française mais c'est son profil qui
nous intéressait ça fait trois ans qu'on
voulait le piéger en fait avec le covid
avec plein de choses on n'a pas pu le
faire et donc il est incroyable en fait
là franchement je le dis je me suis
jamais autant marré que sur cette
technique je te le dis ce soir faites un
kiffe si vous voulez avoir regardez les
gendarmes de mouvement aussi sur la page
mais là les gars là vous allez kiffer on
a le début de ta caméra cachée sur les
premiers échanges avec ton maître de
stage Jacky qui capte tout de suite que
ça va être assez compliqué avec toi il y
avait 11 heures derrière mais il a eu
tellement d'empathie pour moi en fait
parfois il était au bout de sa vie mais
il voulait vraiment me il a l'air gentil
il est super gentil et surtout c'est ce
que je disais à Valerie tout à l'heure
en fait c'est qu'il a de l'humour et ça
c'est le mieux c'est un piéger c'est
qu'il est un grand cœur mais surtout
qu'il est de l'humour et du caractère et
lui il réunissait tout ça et puis c'est
vraiment on voulait piéger un belge
depuis longtemps et ben ça y est c'est
fait
incroyable
c'était avec Evelyne Thomas donc c'est
mon choix
je peux y aller là non
[Musique]
comment réagit votre entourage en vous
voyant faire ces choses-là est-ce qu'ils
ont ils ont pas peur pour vous s'il est
tout le temps avant de le voir
ils sont n'est pas contre du danger mais
un jour ils sont venus devant un système
de mes spectacles
il m'avait demandé d'arrêter et alors
j'ai dit non
[Applaudissements]
j'avais envie de regarder d'aller dans
les émissions de télé comme les gens qui
sont là et puis voilà bah j'ai oui oui
bah là j'étais content parce que une
très belle femme tu étais déjà drôle à
l'époque ils sont directes
[Applaudissements]
on dirait que je vais te tuer des gens
c'est incroyable hein franchement mais
c'est le meilleur c'est le meilleur ah
regarde
sur Youtube depuis des années et je
voudrais dire la fidélité de Greg parce
que tout le monde veut travailler avec
Greg il est toujours avec nous toujours
là et c'est vrai que c'est un amour de
mec avec des fidélité et David que
j'aime dans le couloir là bien sûr qui
est exceptionnel les deux c'est des
amours de mec voilà je voulais le dire
et grâce c'est un mec que j'aime et
David aussi est vraiment voilà je ils
sont dès qu'ils ont un plan voilà un
projet il m'appelle
pour nous attends moi j'ai rien fait si
vous étiez nul je vous aurais viré
depuis longtemps
alors
pour ceux qui ne te connaissent pas
encore ou ceux qui kiffent tes vidéos
vous aurez qu'on voit deux trois petits
trucs parce que c'est vrai que on en
passait beaucoup dans TPMP à l'époque
c'était un moment incroyable et on va
avoir tes vidéos dans les escalators des
centres commerciaux
et les réactions sont magiques ça aussi
c'était très fort
[Musique]
un peu plus longtemps
j'aurais aimé que mon chagrin meurt
qu'un instant
[Musique]
astuce j'espère au moins que tu
m'entends
[Musique]
à l'époque avec trois bouts de ficelle
on avait 9 handicap avec mon pote jeune
de maillot on filmait ça mais tu vois
c'était on s'amusait tellement les
meilleurs souvenirs
en même temps regardez
[Musique]
je rentre
pas
on prend la photo
oui c'est mon patron qui m'a appelé
également piéger l'équipe de TPMP tu
étais venu un peu comme un conseiller
proposer des nouveaux programmes tu
avais que j'ai Castaldi moi aussi on
avait commencé par toi Cyril et après je
te dis faut qu'on fasse les chroniqueurs
et tu as dit c'est une super idée parce
que je crois que vous me connaissiez pas
encore à ce moment-là regarde
quelques propositions pour pour le
relancer
aujourd'hui en télévision qui marche
fort toi tu as un beau corps et donc tu
peux toi dans le rôle du coach
finalement c'est assez crédible et on
s'est dit là que le gimmick ce serait
Casta ça castagne
c'est un problème de voisinage par
exemple tu arrives tu sonnes le mec il
ouvre et direct tu fais le casse à
castagne
[Rires]
et vraiment c'est pas chez moi je me
suis pas barré
dessus non plus un jour que je te casse
mal à la tête on a tout à fait beaucoup
d'entretien comme ça avec des gens je
pense que trois fois sur quatre tu vas
prendre ta tronche quoi déjà tout à
l'heure on était à deux doigts c'est
parti pour que je me calme sinon je te
laisse sauter à la gorge
[Applaudissements]
je peux terminer
[Musique]
c'est magnifique ça on est pas direct
[Applaudissements]
à côté ça serait très mal tourné
tu avais aussi piégé notre pote Julien
Courbet
une émission avec un titre un peu
spécial regardez
un peu le code pénal et ben là tu vas
aller brûler les règles je vais aller
contre la loi le titre du programme un
peu rock'n'roll auquel on a pensé c'est
courber vos pisses à l'arrêt déjà
[Musique]
c'est l'arrêt et l'apostrophe à 2 R e t
et c'est là qu'il y a rien de ce petit
donc c'est l'arrêt de bus c'est là où tu
vas systématiquement les provoquer les
gens je te montre le chewing-gum
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut le revoir
excuse-moi
la vie tu sais de la famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aussi
je me rappelle plus du tout tu rigoles
tout le temps pour rien fais toi
confiance quoi tu es bon quoi tu as du
talent
je veux pas que moi je ramène un truc un
peu plus français
[Rires]
donc l'intérêt en fait c'est que du coup
je cherche tu veux mettre vraiment je
déconne pas
c'est ça
parce que là tous les jours mais
justement
on fait quoi Nîmes ensemble moi c'est
avec ma tête de Breton toi ta tête de
juif
mais c'est vrai que ça peut être drôle
qu'on se fasse des vannes tout le temps
ensuite au niveau des chroniqueurs ça on
fera du ménage
[Musique]
ça fonctionne je trouve quand on
interagit c'est à toi tu m'écoutes je
trouve que tu as de l'écoute bon ben
voilà écoutez on y va du coup là vous
montez avec les choses à dire ou pas on
a ajouté ok on peut se tenir au courant
pour le pognon et tout du coup
je suis désolé je vois vraiment filer on
sait encore tu passes un coup de fil
Ciao
[Applaudissements]
avant toi ouais c'est vrai
mais non j'ai bien aimé
les classiques de tes caméras cachées
dont une partie d'une en particulier
c'est lorsque tu as piéger le gérant
d'un gîte à la montagne s'il vous plaît
à la montagne avec ton personnage donc
du pire stagiaire c'était parti en yox
totalement
piège regardez je vous conseille de
venir voir un joli spectacle dehors avec
votre valise venez tout de suite
regardez regardez
[Musique]
achetez-vous de nouveaux vêtements
maintenant vous me remercierez plus tard
vas-y petit bateau petit fils de [__]
tu lui poses de ça regardez la voiture
j'écris plouk sur la voiture [__] il
m'a [__] ma caisse c'est un nouveau
départ pour une nouvelle vie
petit bâtard
comme ça s'il te plaît
[Applaudissements]
j'arrête la caméra cachée au bon moment
parce qu'on a appris plus tard qu'il
allait chercher quelque chose de nature
tranchante dans son coin donc on a bien
arrêté au bon moment voilà on a appris
après ça il y a un autre classique qui
te rappelle du PS du rappeur JNR ah
ouais ah ouais ça c'était un nouvel
album
depuis combien de temps êtes-vous
rappeur est-ce que vous vivez du rap
alors moi ça fait 4 ans que je rappelle
non j'ai pas du rap mais j'aimerais bien
on travaille pour donc si je comprends
bien vous êtes chômeurs je suis en stage
de chômage
[Rires]
et je pense qu'il n'y aura pas de
reportages de la sorte sur vous
profitez-en journée portes ouvertes au
tocard
on met des bruits comme mes amis
écoute-moi bien mon petit canard si tu
as la dalle il faut que tu quittes la
capitale tu gagnes moins de 10000 € par
mois donc le vote tu ne devrais pas en
avoir le droit comme le dirai papa
personne ne rigole essayer de la journée
[Applaudissements]
juste après TPMP et tu as créé aussi le
pire genre le pire genre
là c'est je suis tellement content de
retrouver le pire stagiaire j'ai hâte de
faire surtout des pierres stagiaires
avec wevegnac moi aussi je suis d'accord
on va on veut le voir plus on veut le
voir plus je te le dis on peut le voir
normalement c'est bon on en tournant
avec wivignac alors le pire genre aussi
tu es piège la famille ta future femme
je voulais qu'on voit lorsque tu avais
piéger les parents de Georgia Girard et
Émilie c'était magique regardez
notre religion même pas j'ai eu un
aperçu dans la Vérité si je mens
je suis quelqu'un de très ouvert
d'esprit je n'hésiterai pas à s'il le
faut même à mettre votre petit chapeau
là sur la tête là là le petit le petit
pancake avec la tout mignon là que vous
avez attendez j'en ai une pour vous
autant que je tiens des Juifs à table
qu'est-ce qu'un qu'est-ce qu'un juif
dans une forêt c'est un
rabbin des bois
et Émilie donc j'imagine que ce sont des
noms d'emprunt
[Musique]
je vous présente Charlie notre excellent
cuisinier enchanté j'ai une très bonne
nouvelle pour vous cela devrait vous
ravir Charlie et de chez vous
il est juif il est juif comme vous vous
devez sûrement avoir beaucoup de choses
à vous raconter vous pouvez peut-être
parler de Patrick Bruel et boulettes
Tel-Aviv ces choses-là je n'avais jamais
rencontré de Juifs
le seul que je connaissais était le
pitre de la télévision là Cyril Hanouna
oui
mais finalement mon cuisinier aux zizi
coupé est très bien vous êtes juif et
arabe en même temps
vous cherchez les problèmes
que non
on peut rigoler sur des choses mais il y
a des choses que le respect
c'était incroyable
le dernier en date c'est en novembre
lorsque tu as péché Eugène et Brigitte
la famille congolaise le père voulait se
fracasser
plus vite regardez regardez
non non moi je veux être gentil avec tes
fans tu n'es pas j'écris avec moi et je
suis désolé
palette pardon pardon si tu veux non
pardon Guigui ça se dit pas je sais pas
ce que j'ai fait de mal je sais pas ce
que j'ai fait
pas non mais je suis d'accord avec
Eugène
bah oui attends c'est la belle famille
et toi tu dis des bêtises comme ça je
voulais bien vous recevoir
c'est pour ça il est énervé
maman
incroyable
j'ai perdu un peu de poids sur ce piège
longtemps en fait on avait c'était prévu
pour durer 5 heures et au bout de 15
minutes dans une demi-heure ça se passe
comme ça donc on a composé avec voilà la
police est arrivée parce que n'importe
quoi ce piège